[Música]
[Aplausos]
imaginad que un dios levantáis y tenéis
86.400 eurazos en vuestra cuenta
bancaria
podríais vivir sin preocupaciones y no
trabajar si de verdad os apasiona lo que
hacéis y sabiendo que al día siguiente
volveréis a tener 86.400 eurazos
estaría guay no vivir en un mundo así
hola
gracias por estar aquí conmigo
pues tengo una buena noticia y la
noticia es que todos nosotros tenemos 86
mil 400 segundos
con lo que hacer algo
y eso ya da un poquito más de miedo es
el consciente de todo el tipo que más
gastaba al día me hacía sentirme fatal
conmigo mismo y decidí tomar acción y
mejorar un campo que me apasiona que es
el de la memoria
y cité con los resultados
se queda embelesado el pobre mirándome
ahora llegan gracias por ayudarme de
verdad
esto es un libro el número del número pi
el número pi es un número y nació
irracional que cuenta de una parte
entera el 3 una coma y luego una
infinidad de números que van hasta donde
nadie ha sido capaz de averiguar y es
con esa parte con la que yo me lo paso
genial
te importaría por favor más [ __ ] el
libro es un libro normal sólo que en vez
de tener palabras tiene decimales del
número pi y se le tal cual entonces marc
por favor para ver qué tal me ayuda a mí
esto siéntate quiero que abras el libro
por una página a la que tú quieras
en este libro tiene 10.000 decimales y
obviamente no me 12 todos 9.500 2600
depende del día así que te voy a pedir
por fa que abras una página pero no
vayas más allá de la página 150 160
porque me bailan los números vale te
sabe por donde tú quieras incline libro
hacia ti para que no pueda ver y dime en
qué página estás
85 ha dicho
ah bueno perdón perdón que sigue
diciendo decimales y tú no dices nada el
resto van a flipar igual
entonces perdona fallo mío no te lo he
dicho yo voy diciendo decimales si voy
bien todo genial si hago algún taquillo
pues pórtate bien y piña a las cargados
y listo vale pero dime si esa página
empieza por un 3
voy de carrerilla vale
317 01 47 41 91 27 53 sí sí sí
fue la tela de la tela marinera pero si
realmente me superan los decimales del
número pi no tendría que necesitar que
alguien me dijera una página pues por
favor acerca del libro justa la chica
que tienes detrás de ti ella misma hola
qué tal cómo te llamas que tal patricia
todo bien mira patricia si yo por
ejemplo tengo esta secuencia tú como la
sigues
j l m n t
respetado
pero de una secuencia de símbolos que
todos conocemos que es el alfabeto es
fácil saber en qué punto de la secuencia
estamos y seguir desde allí hacerlo con
diez mil y tantos decimales no es tan
sencillo para pedir por sacar ese libro
por donde tú quieras eso si no vas allá
más allá de las 150 160 pórtate bien con
el mago ya que estamos no y te fijas en
cinco dígitos consecutivos que estén
juntitos
los tienes vale por fin dime el primero
de ellos
vamos bien
no sabemos dónde estamos pero nivel
segunda por fa
siguiente
pero espero
creo que el quinto no hace falta que me
lo digas cuál es el siguiente número que
siga la secuencia
espera que voy espera que voy
19 12 7 53 84 57
no perdón perdón perdón 290
esto ya es casi casi el ego del artista
hacer está un montón pero donde me
quedaba
384 57
6 03 34 39 76 10
momia
es que tú es todo pero claro gracias por
ayudarme de verdad que eres
si de verdad me superan los decimales
del número pi no necesitaría que alguien
me dijera una página o que alguien me
dijera una combinación de números dentro
del libro tendría que ser capaz de
encontrar cualquier combinación de
dígitos dentro del mismo
podrías por favor pasarle el libro a la
persona que tienes justo al lado
hola qué tal estás y
y hacerlo con el número pin pero para no
hacerlo todo tan personal voy a hacerlo
con tu fecha de cumpleaños te parece
pero por cuestiones de educación vamos a
obviar el año vale no sólo por eso sino
porque así hay más posibilidades de que
tu número esté dentro del libro en mi
caso mi fecha de cumpleaños el 17 de
julio 1707 este sería el número a buscar
dentro del libro y el documento porque
está cerquita y nos cuestan a
felicitarme en truena
estamos entonces cuál sería tu fecha de
cumpleaños por fin
02 08
agosto
qué pasa no tiene sus debilidades pues
este sería el número a buscar dentro del
libro primero voy a decirte si justo
este número está dentro del libro vale
pero así está
y además está la parte que me cuesta
02/08
vale no sólo creo que va a ser capaz de
decirte la página que está al final sino
también la línea
y en qué posición dentro de la línea
creo que justo esos cuatro dígitos están
en la página 174
en la línea 2
al final
si o no
tiene que sí sí sí los acercarme libros
madre mía qué maravilla
bueno
y esto han sido cinco años de mi vida
cinco años de vida
y ahí
tal porque realmente ha merecido la pena
invertir tantas hay tantas y tantas
horas memorizando decimales antes de
salir a escena no lo tenía muy claro y
después de ver vuestra reacción un
poquito más pero creo que ahí es donde
entra de verdad el talento en ser
capaces de decidir si una cosa a la otra
sin memorizar decimales o no
o no madre mía qué locura qué locura yo
pienso que claro porque elegimos y por
qué lo elegimos pienso que el talento de
alguna forma resuena con lo que nos
gusta y con lo que somos realmente
buenos simplemente tenemos que ser lo
suficientemente sensibles como para ser
capaces de sentir esa atracción natural
hacia ciertas disciplinas yo hace
muchísimos años me enamoré de la magia y
me llevo libro tarot al libro lo lees
aprendes disfrutas te emocionas ensayas
practicas te vuelves a emocionar y
descubrir que alguna forma puedes contar
lo que llevas dentro y te emocionas
contándolo y puedes conseguir que la
gente al final se acabe emocionando
contigo y eso sí que es maravilloso
eso sí qué maravilloso
también encanta de alguna forma escuchar
esa vocecita en mi interior que se llama
talento la que me ayuda a tomar
decisiones porque tomar decisiones no es
nada fácil claro toda decisión requiere
de un sacrificio que la silicona una
cosa estoy dejando de lado otra
si elijo memorizar decimales no estoy en
la playa
y estoy contentísimo de que todos
vosotros hayáis decidido hoy sacrificar
un mundo entero de posibilidades por
estar aquí con nosotros entre el
archiduque
es que es maravilloso y lo bonito que es
es sentir esa incertidumbre el no saber
el no saber si de verdad hemos tomado la
decisión correcta
qué pasa si todo lo que es sacrificado
por esta decisión al final se echa a
perder porque esto que yo pensaba que
iba a ser la leche al final no
qué pasa si no tomamos la decisión
correcta
pues no pasa nada
claro que no pasa nada que no el
problema es que vivimos en una sociedad
que está enfocada a premiar el éxito y
el fracaso es kaká el fracaso no vale
como es eso posible como es eso posible
el fracaso no tendría que ser una
preocupación tendría que ser algo de lo
que nos beneficiemos claro que sí thomas
alva edison uno de los grandes
inventores de la historia de la
humanidad él decía que él no fracaso 999
veces antes de descubrir la bombilla
sin embargo encontró 999 formas de como
no hacer una bombilla
claro [ __ ] esta gente lo tenía
clarísimo dejemos que nuestro talento se
nutra de nuestros errores para así ser
mejores porque cuanto más fracasemos más
preparados estaremos para tomar las
decisiones correctas dejemos que esa
vocecita que tenemos dentro nos guíe a
través de los errores dejemos que el
talento coja la rienda de nuestras vidas
es que esto
es que me emociono sólo de pensarlo
qué estamos haciendo qué estamos
haciendo
por qué
claro tú te pones a pensar y dices hoy
no hoy no y no estás ahí detrás hoy no
hoy no es el día no es el día sale la
gente tabloides hoy es el día porque no
va a ser el día toma la decisión es coge
las riendas y al final acabará siendo o
lo que tiene que ser un aprendizaje para
que la próxima vez todo es la decisión
que de verdad tenías que haber tomado
es que tenemos que ser insaciables
tenemos que de alguna forma somos la
única persona que nos pone nuestros
límites o mejor aún somos la única
persona que tenía que dejar de ponerse
límites tengo la responsabilidad de ser
mejores día a día
y el talento como gran poder conlleva
una gran responsabilidad
la responsabilidad de ser mejores de
conocerse de fracasar de aprender de los
errores de estar en esa búsqueda
continua de lo que de verdad nos
apasiona y nos llena por dentro lo que
somos realmente buenos de lo que alguna
vez podemos llegar a ser realmente
felices y quién sabe tal vez hacer
felices a los demás
mi tiempo en este escenario está
llegando a su fin
y yo sigo sin saber si elegido las
palabras correctas esta tarde aquí junto
a vosotros sigo sin saber si ha merecido
la pena todo lo que se esté contando y
que alguna de las ideas que se ha
lanzado resuenan en vuestra cabeza con
vuestros pensamientos
pero qué bonito es no saber y estoy
contentísimo porque he estado escuchando
esa voz interior con la que he tenido
infinidad de diálogos de los que han
salido esto que os esté presentando aquí
a vosotros
y es que es una maravilla voy contento
ahí un poquito preocupado porque sigo
sin saber si está que se esté contando
ha servido para nada
lo que único que sí sé es que yo encima
de este escenario he dado mi máximo a
estos 1080 segundos que he compartido
con vosotros
la pregunta es
de los 86 mil 400 euros que tenéis todos
y cada uno de vosotros al día cuantos
estáis dispuestos a invertir en vosotros
en vuestro talento
y en ser más felices
[Aplausos]
y